guerre d'usure donc que france 24 couvre
grâce à ses reporters bonjour tarek
kayes vous êtes de retour de mission en
ukraine où vous étiez également sur
place au début de la guerre en trois
mois qu'est ce qui a changé
il s'agit de la deuxième en fait du
deuxième séjour qu'on effectuera en
ukraine après celui qu'on avait effectué
au tout début du conflit s'était en mars
dernier l époque ce que nous avions vu
on était plutôt à l'ouest du pays c'est
à dire après mèche du côté de la pologne
et à lviv du côté a à l'ouest de
l'ukraine ce que l'on voyait c'était 7
dizaines de milliers de civils qui
fuyait les régions bombardé du nord ou
de l'est il arrivait donc par milliers
pour fuir cet enfer ce qui était
frappant est fatiguant de voir c'était
de recueillir tous ces témoignages de
gens complètement déboussolé de
personnes âgées de femmes d'enfants
parfois de nourrissons qui arrivait à
elles vivent pour échapper à cet enfer
il attendait pendant des heures de jour
comme de nuit sous la pluie sous la
neige dans des températures glaciales
pour pouvoir échapper à la guerre il
était il nous racontait il nous faisait
part un peu de ce qu'ils avaient vécu
des bombardements de la vie sous
l'occupation russe en ce qui concerne le
dernier séjour c'était plutôt les effets
de la guerre l'impact de la guerre et je
dirais le visage salle de la guerre avec
les bombardements qui n'ont épargné
aucune ville aucun village et avec ses
villes et ses villages qui sont presque
complètement désert avec ces
bombardements qui continue partout on a
été il ya eu des frappes
que ce soit à odessa amicaux la nive
admis pro et encore plus dans nos bases
des bombardements qui se poursuivent
actuellement aucun bombardement
l'epargne les villages les villes vous
lui disiez tarek ça veut dire que
couvrir ce conflit pour les journalistes
est un risque tout à fait c'est un
risque pour les journalistes aussi bien
que pour les civils qui vivent toujours
dans ces villes comme je l'avais 10
aucune ville aujourd'hui n'était pas
renié pas le conflit aucune ville n'est
à l'abri des frappes russes et même si
l'effort de l'armée russe se concentre
actuellement sur le dombass ces villes
elles peuvent être ciblés c'est ce que
nous avions expérimentés nous mêmes dès
notre arrivée à odessa dans le sud du
pays avec lux ragots à titre d'exemple
on était en train d'interviewer une
déplacée qui venait de recentrer sonne
donc la ville qui est sous occupation
russe elle nous faisait part de ses
difficultés de la vie à sous-occupation
russe quand on a entendu un bruit qui
s'apparentait à celui d'un avion de
chasse qui volait à très basse altitude
il s'est avéré qu'il ne s'agissait pas
d'un avion de chasse mais deux missiles
qui ont été attirés et conquis on qui
volent et à 100 mètres au dessus de nos
têtes c'était la première fois
personnellement que je voyais des
missiles en voie de laterrière et ou de
toucher leur cible résultat des courses
c'est me sylla ont touché un de ces
missiles a touché un immeuble
résidentiel a fait huit morts partout on
a été les maires encouragent les
habitants à quitter les villes parce que
les bombardements peuvent arriver à
n'importe quel moment de la journée et
de la nuit des bombardements continus
qui constitue un danger aussi bien pour
les civils que pour les jeunes et face
aux russes tarek il ya bien sûr ces
combattants ukrainien cette résistance
ukrainienne nous marque nous occidentaux
est ce qu'elles restent intactes encore
lé attaque tel est très présente cette
détermination
ukrainienne qu'il s'agisse de soldats ou
de simples civils si on veut tirer des
conclusions ou des points communs entre
les deux expériences nos propres
expériences sur le terrain c'est
justement cette détermination qui
restent intactes qui est très présente
nous l'avions senti dès le premier jour
quand on parlait aux différents
interlocuteurs ukrainiens qu'ils
s'agissent d'officiels de simples
citoyens ou de soldats ils nous disaient
qu'ils allaient gagner la guerre et on
avait du mal à imaginer comment l'armée
ukrainienne pourrait tenir trois mois
après cette armée iranienne tient
toujours et s'il faut illustré en
choisissant un des exemples pour
illustrer cette détermination
ukrainienne on peut la trouver chez ces
volontaires de la défense territoriale
il s'agit de volontaires qui ont rejoint
les rangs de l'armée des jeunes qui
n'ont aucune expérience militaire et qui
ont décidé du jour au lendemain
d'aller à combattre on les a rencontrés
sur l'un des fronts le front 10e
certains avaient rejoint la défense
territoriale en 2014 pour combattre pour
défendre le dombass et la crimée et
d'autres ont décidé de rejoindre la
défense est réparé hier il ya juste à
quelques mois et je vous propose
d'écouter quelques témoignages
nous voulons nous battre sur le front le
commandant peut vous appeler dans la
nuit vous dire que les russes pagny fine
attaques de chars vous donner l'ordre à
votre bataillon de défendre sa section
sur la ligne de front et vos soldats
vont se battre contre des chars ce n'est
pas une blague c'est un dur combat
passant je travaillais dans les mines il
y a eu des explosions et un gars est
mort à deux mètres de moi donc je suis
calme quand je vois la mort combattre
combattre ceux qui sont sans honneur
qu'il soit de votre famille ou pas cela
n'a pas d'importance la russie
représente le mal à l'échelle planétaire
s'il ya conflit quelque part vous y
trouverez la main du kremlin j'en suis à
99 à 100% sur
ce
dernier point peut-être ce soldat
convient d'écouter il s'agit d'un
citoyen russe qui a décidé de rejoindre
l'armée ukrainien de la défense
territoriale ce qui montre encore plus
la détermination qu'on peut trouver chez
chez ses soldats merci infiniment tariq
ali pour votre témoignage et coup de
chapeau bien sûr à tous nos reporters
sur le terrain leur travail est vraiment
essentiel